[Music]
time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week first up a
worrisome rise in the occurrence of
liver cancer it's been increasing since
the mid 1970s and according to a new
report conducted by the American Cancer
Society
liver cancer death rates are rising
faster than any other form of the
disease with the death rate doubling
since the mid 1980s the American Cancer
Society estimates that this year there
will be nearly 41,000 new cases and
close to 29,000 deaths here to talk
about it is CBS news chief medical
correspondent dr. Jon LaPook and CBS
News contributor dr. Tara Narula good
morning to you both
morning Tara did the report give any
reason for the rise in cancer well the
interesting thing about liver cancer is
that 60% of it is attributable to
potentially modifiable risk factors some
of those risk factors have been
increasing over the past few decades
things like type 2 diabetes and obesity
in addition alcohol plays a role we know
that there's a 10% increase in the risk
per drink per day and smoking which we
think of as associated with lung cancer
actually increases the risk of liver
cancer by about 50% and then you have to
think about hepatitis hepatitis B and C
globally hepatitis B is really the
biggest cause of liver cancer in this
country really only the cause of less
than 5% of liver cancers but hepatitis C
very prevalent high numbers in that baby
boomer population those born between
1945 and 1965 they actually count for
about 80 percent of the cases of
hepatitis C in this country dr. LaPook
there were significant disparities in
terms of who was affected by this what
is what can you tell us me yeah and you
know as I'm listening to you I want to
point out to our viewers we are talking
about cancer that starts in the liver
not cancer that starts somewhere else
and spreads to the liver which of course
is deadly but yes there are a lot of
racial disparities ethnic disparities as
with other cancers we're seeing and the
lowest death rate was in whites then
blacks Hispanics Asian and Pacific
Islanders and the greatest death rate
was an American Indians and Alaska
Natives and they're different with more
than twice that of whites and it's felt
largely due to different differences in
these risk factors that Tara was talking
about and to some extent to access to
care Tara did the authors suggest there
was any way to reverse these trends well
it's important for us to look at
because the prognosis for liver cancer
is not great we know that survival of
five years after diagnosis about one in
five so clearly we can affect these
modify loris factors so better control
of diabetes weight control decreased
alcohol avoiding smoking and then when
you look at those hepatitis factors you
want to make sure that people are
vaccinated for hepatitis B which became
part of routine childhood vaccinations
in 1982 and for Hep C do we need to do a
better job in terms of surveillance and
screening the CDC recommends that
everyone born in that baby boomer
generation get tested at least once and
then treatment in 2014 we have new oral
drugs that can treat hepatitis C very
good cure rates low risk low side effect
rates and so that would be important and
then finally looking at populations that
are at high risk and really targeting
those so people who are incarcerated and
those with needle sharing to try to
avoid that as well good words of wisdom
our next topic something we all
experience stomach problems a recently
really serve a by Merck manuals part of
the merck pharmaceutical company looked
at how Americans deal with digestive
discomfort a little over 2,000 American
adults participated the survey found
that nearly a quarter of people
experienced digestive discomfort once a
week or more and only 16% who
experienced digestive discomfort visited
a doctor and the sort of doesn't
surprise me any surprises dr. Luke what
are the other finding surprising well
about 45 percent tried to treat it
themselves with over-the-counter
medicines about 35 percent adjusted
their diet
about 27 percent just dealt with it they
just I guess toughed it out at about 22
percent sought some sort of alternative
medicine some natural remedy Tara what
kind of strategies to people have for
trying to eliminate foods from their guy
well about 18 percent just eliminated
them right on the spot and with the ones
that they thought were contributing
about 47 percent decreased their
exposure to things that they thought
they might be intolerant to 32 percent
conducted their own research and about
13 to 14 percent talked to friends and
family or tried taking medications as
John mention but I think the important
thing is that lots of times just seeing
a doctor and getting tested and going
over your family history and what your
triggers might be is really more
important and can be beneficial than
people just suffering
and trying to diagnose themselves
running to the bathroom as they
mentioned embarrassed you know - to the
bathroom over stretched pants dirty it's
it's something that so many Americans
deal with doc and it's your feel to
steer a your expertise yes I what's I
mean like what's surprising to you in
all of this well what yeah what stood
out was how many people have a
gastrointestinal problem and then how
few people seek the help of a doctor
they said a doctor in the survey or
other clinician I would say can can also
help I am a gastroenterologist I am
biased one of the reasons why you do
need to go to somebody a clinician is
that there are so many different things
that can cause gastrointestinal problems
I mean it could be stress it could be
diet it could be some underlying problem
like inflammatory bowel disease or
celiac disease very often diet if you're
lactose intolerant or some other thing
the way to handle this is to go to
somebody have them sit down and very
carefully slowly go over your diet it's
very tough to figure it out yourself
because there are so many different
factors I take people through their day
what do you have for breakfast what do
you have for lunch and very often
something will come out and it's such an
amazing feeling to be able to
somebody'll come after 20 years and it's
nothing too simple just like you have a
lactose intolerance and so it's one of
the reasons why I love being a GI is you
can really help people if they don't
come to you then it's it's tough to help
them but which is why I like morning
rounds because we can go to that right
all right finally they're often
considered part of the family but along
with companionship can having a dog
improves your health well a new study
published by biomed central look at the
impact of owning a dog for people 65 and
older in the UK the study found owning a
dog led to an average 22 minutes of
additional walking time and dog owners
had significantly less time when they
were City what about cat owners does it
count for me if my wife walks the dog
you points for that
but I would say go get a dog they're
great I love my dog ash little ash
doctor's Jon LaPook Darren a rule always
good to see you thanks for your time